[Musique]
Éric allinuness bonjour bonjour Patrice
carmous on va parler de culture ça vous
étonne pas ça m'étonne pas du tout non
vous êtes le le vice-président de 5 en
charge de de la culture et puis nous
sommes ici dans un des lieux symboliques
de la culture qui est le le théâtre de
Saint-Quentin qui se trouve dans un
périmètre aussi très symbolique de la
culture puisqu'il y a la médiathèque il
y a le théâtre il y a le le musée de la
ville d'illeurs la culture dans une
ville nouvelle comme comme SaintQuentin
est-ce que vous diriez que ça tient lieu
à la fois d'histoire de lien social
entre les habitants bah je crois que la
culture de toute façon elle a toujours
été une facteur d'intégration et de lien
social je on fait identité que ce soit
dans un territoire dans un pays dans une
nation ou quoi que ce soit d'autre au
travers d'une culture et à Saint-Quentin
niveline ben il y avait une période il y
avait que des immigrés puisque les gens
venaient d'ailleurs saintctin n'existit
pas et donc je dirais que dans cette
dans cette importation de cette
population qui venait d'un petit peu
partout bah la culture a été vraiment un
élément essentiel du lien social et
d'ailleurs elle est dans l'ADN de 50 ans
d'Eline puisque très tôt lorsque parce
que la ville nouvelle s'est constitué
les lieux de culture se sont arrivés
quasiment en même temps que les
habitants c'est ça absolument voilà et
donc ça c'est donc les habitants se
laissont appropri aussi he c'est ça oui
oui et puis il faut savoir que bah cette
ville elle s'est construite de par
quartier ce qui fait que en dehors des
quartiers il y avait des champs et que
donc forcément il fallait des lieux pour
se retrouver et les lieux de culture bah
c'était des lieux désignés justement
pour cette cette cette mise en commun de
de de de de cet univers nouveau que les
gens partageaient absolument alors dans
le dernier numéro de skibag avec votre
collègue par un merc qui est qui est le
maire de de Montini on a parlé justement
de la rénovation de l'hypercentre et
dans cet hypercentre il y a le théâtre
et qui lui aussi va faire l'objet d'une
rénovation importante vous avez choisi
l'équipe
d'architectes seul hein
mais qui va procéder à cette rénovation
qui va commencer au mois de janvier donc
il va y avoir une saison hors les murs
très importante ici pendant pendant les
travaux on va on va revenir avec Lionel
messeta sur sur ce ce projet de de
d'aménagement et de modification du
théâtre qu'est-ce qui vous paraît
important dans ce dans ce projet et ce
théâtre au départ il a été conçu comme
un théâtre c'estit dire un lieu
uniquement dédié au spectac aujourd'hui
un théâtre si si on veut qu'il vive il
faut qu'il soit autre chose donc il faut
qu'il soit un lieu ouvert sur la cité
donc l'idée de cette avancée des de de
qui va qui va être mise en œuvre c'est
que le théâtre aille sur la ville et
aille au contact des gens pour que les
gens bah viennent au contact du théâtre
en dehors des soirs de représentation et
c'est ça qui est important c'est de dire
que le le théâtre doit devenir un lieu
de vie et pas il y pas que les
spectaclesul qui qui s'y déroule bah je
vous propose de retrouver Lionel masseta
le directeur du théâtre qui va nous
expliquer en quoi consiste ce projet de
de rénovation et comment il s'inscrit
selon lui Ben dans la continuité de de
ce qu'a fait l'architecte de ce théâtre
qui était stadislas Fisher stadislas
Fisher
absolument le gros changement il va être
pour l'espace urbain c'est-à-dire ce
parvie qui pour l'instant est est
découvert va être recouvert et c'est
finalement en fait presque le projet qui
était imaginé par l'architecte du
théâtre il y a 30 ans Stanislas fishcher
dans son premier projet le parvis était
couvert avec un bar et un restaurant qui
était sur le parvis bien entendu avec
une une couche contemporaine mais qui va
totalement
modifier beaucoup de choses dans un
premier temps la perception que les
passants que les habitués du théâtre que
les spectateurs hon de l'ensemble de ce
bâtiment puisque parve ne sera plus nu
mais qu'il abritera à la fois une
cuisine un restaurant un bar un espace
d'accueil c'estàdire qu'il va y avoir
600 une surface de 600 m² supplémentaire
qui sera visible du bout de l'avenue du
centre en fait c'est concomitant avec la
volonté de l'agglomération et de et de
la ville de Montini de repenser ce qu'on
appelle l'hypercentre de 5501 en Eveline
donc on gagne de l'espace on gagne de la
modularité on gagne de la fonctionnalité
et ça devient un véritable lieu de vie
peut-être ce qui manquait un tout petit
peu à ce théâtre c'était un lieu de vie
les soirs de représentation mais grâce
aux travaux ça va devenir un lieu de vie
au quotidien puisque le restaurant sera
ouvert midi et soir et que le lieu ne
sera pas uniquement réservé à ceux qui
pratiquent le
[Musique]
théâtre ce qui a présidé à ces travaux
c'est véritablement d'arriver à créer ce
lien en fait le parvis était comme dans
la mesure où il était très peu utilisé
était comme un élément de de de
séparation entre cette façade et la
place Pompidou en recouvrant le parvis
avec une couverture qui est assez basse
c'est-à-dire en fait qui ne fait que
sarimer au bâtiment sans le toucher
c'est-à-dire qu'on garde l'historique de
ce bâtiment on garde son esthétique à
part que cette couverture va permettre
de créer ce lien comme un trait d'union
entre le théâtre et la place Pompidou et
surtout je pense que ce bâtiment a
encore puisque les travaux n'ont pas
encore débutés quelque chose qui peut
être un tout petit peu un aspect un peu
intimidant et cet aspect intimidant les
travaux devrai le
gommer Éric à la jeunesse autre lieu
onblématique de de la culture son les
les les médiathèques alors il y en a
beaucoup qui ont été rénovés comme à
traape
notammentsument il y en a une qui va qui
va voir le jour je crois en 2024 à Mani
Amou enfin il y a une il y a combien sur
le territoire de de médiathèque il y a
12 médiathèques sur le territoire
pratiquement une par commun c'est ça
c'est c'est un lieu très important enfin
pour pour la culture très fréquenté ça
marche bien très fréquenté ça marche
très très bien toutes les médiathèques
ont chacune leur personnalité elles ont
chacune leur identité et puis ce sont
des lieux de rencontre et ce sont des
lieux qui sont très fréquentés par les
enfants dès le plus jeune âge avec des
activités justement qui permettent à ces
jeunes c'estes tout petits de de venir
se s'imerger déjà dans la culture la
culture alors vous disiez il y a il y a
12 he médiiathèque sur le territoire
c'està dire que voilà il y a une
proximité formidable dans presque chaque
chaque ville du territoire mais il y a
quelque chose de plus c'est la mise en
réseau et ça c'est très important
c'estàd que on peut obtenir où qu'on
soit la même chose que si on est
ailleurs si je peux dire exactement et
c'est c'est un petit peu la volonté de
de de de 50 ans div justement d'offrir à
tous les habitants quel qu'ils soi dans
n'importe quel commun de pouvoir accès
au même contenu donc il y a quand même
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire le
réseau vraiment trouve son originalité
dans dans le mode de fonctionnement des
médiiaathèques à 50 ans livin c'est que
toute personne qui par exemple
trouverait un un livre ou un un disque
qui se trouverait par exemple quelqu'un
habitait à en cour le le contenu choisi
se trouve à montigier ben il va le
commander et on va le lui amener à
encour la personne n'aura même pas
besoin d'aller évidemment avec on peut
tous les habitants de tout le territoire
avoir accès à toutes les médiathèques
mais aussi dans leur médiathèque la
petite ou grande ils ont accès au
contenu de toutes les autres
médiiathèques ça c'est ex extraordinaire
donc il a des navettes qui se font et
qui amèent des documents ça c'est voilà
c'est le cœur du réseau il est là aussi
il est pas que dans le réseau numérique
effectivement et ça aussi ça crée un
lien entre les habitants du territoire
évidemment un lien et puis une égalité
je vous propose de retrouver Pascal V
qui est le directeur des des médiatek
qui nous explique leur fonctionnement et
qui insiste aussi sur l'importance de
l'offre
numérique le grand principe de
fonctionnement du réseau des
médiathèques de 50 ans en Eveline c'est
des équipements de proximité dans leur
commune en adéquation avec leur public
mais qui bénéficient de l'apport et de
la valeur ajoutée d'un fonctionnement en
réseau avec la mutualisation de toutes
les ressources possibles qu'ell soit
documentaire d'action culturelle ou de
service comme le transit qui permet au
collections de circuler d'une médiataque
à
l'autre l'offre culture en ligne sur le
portail permet aussi un accès distance à
des vidéos par exemple de rencontrre
avec des auteurs qui vont déambuler dans
une médiathèque et à travers une
sélection d'ouvrages expliquer ce qui
les a construit dans la littérature dans
les essais et cetera on peut avoir aussi
une offre de compte en ligne donc là bah
ça peut être très intéressant pour les
parents pour aussi proposer à leurs
enfants des lectures à voix
[Musique]
haute avoir une offre numérique ça
permet d'atteindre un public qui est un
peu plus éloigné du livre donc là on
arrive aussi leur proposer un service
intéressant et pour les personnes qui
sont toujours des utilisatrices de
livres et bien l'offre numérique vient
apporter des contenus complémentaires
qui viennent enrichir l'offre des
médiathèques le dernier roman de la
rentrée littéraire un documentaire qui
vous intéresse vous pouvez y accéder en
format papier classique mais vous pouvez
y accéder aussi sous forme numérique ça
vous donne aussi accès à de la musique
en streaming on a à la fois une
dématérialisation de la musique mais on
a aussi un retour du Viny qui marche
très bien donc là on fait grand écart
entre le retour de l'analogique et une
offre musicale en numérique streaming on
a aussi la presse en ligne et on a aussi
une offre
d'autoformation ça peut être un cours de
langue ça peut être un cours pour
préparer l'épreuvve du code de la route
ça peut être de l'aide pour les jeunes
collégiens élèves pour leurs
[Musique]
devoirs le cœur de l'activité pour les
médiiathèques et les bibliothécaires
c'est d'être des passeurs et de faire de
la médiation traditionnellement vous
avez la médiation en direction des
documents en direction des contenus
aujourd'hui on faire de la médiation en
direction des technologies et en
direction des nouvelles formes que le
numérique pourra prendre les trois axes
principaux sur lesquels on travaille
actuellement c'est les fablabes donc
c'est l'accès à des outils qui
permettent de fabriquer des choses
imprimant 3D notamment c'est la
robotique comment se l'approprier
comment a mieux la connaître et le
codage par exemple où on va essayer
aussi de créer des médiations pour
permettre une appropriation de ces
compétences on est juste à côté de la
médiathèque et dans le trème M
emblématique de la culture c'est le le
budget de la villeument on pourrait se
dire mais qu'est-ce que vient faire un
musée dans une ville nouvelle au fond
mais quand on regarde on a un peu la
réponse on a la réponse c'està dire
qu'il y a beaucoup de design évidemment
ou beaucoup de design des années 7080
qui s'inscrivent au moment de la
création de la ville nouvelle l'idée ça
était de dire bah on va on va essayer de
de de de calquer un petit peu avec le
mode de vie de ces années qu'on appelle
les années pop dont beaucoup d'orange
beaucoup de couleurs et puis le musée
bon attendez il y a pas que le musée
dans ces murs il il y a le musée à ciel
ouvert parce qu'il faut savoir que voilà
voilà c'est comme c'est un peu c'est un
peu le j'allais dire le la la l'identité
de la culture à à saint-contin c'est que
ça n'est pas que dans les murs c'est
aussi h les murs murs c'est les œuvres
que dont les que les gens se sont
appropriés avec le temps auquel on fait
même plus attention et qui pourtant sont
bel et bien là à 800 m d'ici il y a la
l'arche de Kowalski 200 m il y a la
perspective de martapan sont des des ce
sont des des artistes extrêmement
célèbres qui nous ont qui nous ont
apporté justement cette spécificité
l'idée c'était justement de donner une
identité forte à ce territoire on
pouvait pas le faire avec l'histoire
puisque l'histoire elle se crée au jour
le jour on l'a fait avec la culture et
la culture c'est une source d'identité
comme on disait tout à l'heure et quand
on vit ici c'est vrai qu'on vit au
milieu de l'art urbain
quoi et dont dont le musée est
responsable aussi exactement alors on va
on va quand même le visiter ce ce ce
musée avec son directeur Frédéric Deb et
jeose donc cette cette visite guidé du
musée donc l' grande importance
naturellement des œuvres de design on en
a vu quelques-unes et aussi de
l'architecture de de cette ville don
dont le musé Ren compte on rejoint
Frédéric Debche
[Musique]
50 ans en yeline en tant que ville
nouvelle est un exemple extrêmement
intéressant de la façon de faire les
villes et de d'aménager le territoire à
une certaine époque il y a eu CIN villes
nouvelles construites autour de Paris à
partir des an 70 c'est une histoire qui
rentre maintenant dans dans la grande
histoire de l'aménagement urbain du
territoire dans l'histoire des villes et
à citre là c'est un sujet à faire
connaître et à faire
reconnaître la collection design qui
s'est développé dans les années 90 avait
pour fonction d'illustrer le cadre
intime de l'habitation le chez soi pour
faire pendant en quelque sorte à
l'architecture et au cadre urbain et les
deux fonctionnent fonctionne en
écho c'est un dialogue qui qui
fonctionne relativement bien deutant que
architecture et design sont deux
disciplines artistiques mais qui sont
relativement proches et qui partent
d'une notion d'usage avant tout on
construit une architecture pour un usage
on crée un mobilier pour la maison pour
un
usage notre collection design
aujourd'hui c'est 3200 objets et c'est
l'une des principales collections euh
publque en France en matière de de
design le musée déploie aussi toute une
série d'actions hors les murs sur les
territoires en lien avec les communes
cette année en 2023 on aborde
l'architecture liée au sièges
d'entreprise aux immeubles de bureaux
l'architecture tertière puisque
sa-quentin en ieline en tant que ville
nouvelle a été conçu avec cette
dimension économique très importante et
une un équilibre entre les les fonctions
résidentielles et économiques et donc
cette fonction économique se traduit à
travers toute une série de bâtiments
d'entreprise qui sont assez
spectaculaires pour pour
certains alors Éric alin juness un des
axes forts de de la politique culturelle
que vous entendez mener ça concerne la
culture scientifique c'est c'est un un
besoin un besoin une nécessitéah je
crois que c'est une nécessité parce que
la culture scientifique je pense qu'on
peut pas en faire l'économie aujourd'hui
dans un monde qui est très technologique
on parle beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle de toutes ces choses et je
crois surtout que une une tête bien
faite c'est une tête qui comprend les
processus qui comprend les éléments
basiques de de de la physique moi
j'aiétaé très très choqué lorsque j'ai
lu un article où il était il faisait
état d'un sondage qui disait que un
jeune sur 6 entre 15 et 25 ans pense que
la terre est plate ça a été pour moi un
électrochoc je me suis dit bon on peut
pas continuer comme ça je crois qu'il y
a vraiment des fondamentaux à mettre en
œuvre et et la culture scientifique fait
partie de ce bagage indispensable pour
être un homme libre tout simplement
enfin quand je dis un homme un être
libre exactement mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut lutter contre ces désinformations
c'estes fake ces réseaux sociaux parfois
qui emplissent notamment les jeunes de
mauvaises nouvelles de fausses nouvelles
et la culture la culture et la science
c'est vrai que vont ensemble tout à fait
c'est c'est la même chose et quand on
voit un petit peu tout ce qui s'est
produit et qui se produit encore sur
certains médicaments sur les vaccins à
l'époque du covid on a envie que chacun
a un bagage minimal pour lui permettre
de ne pas euh absorber toutes sortes de
désinformations mais de comprendre par
lui-même des processus et de de
s'affranchir d'une certaine manière de
la tutelle du on dit et et et et et des
des des fausses nouvelles par hasard si
un médecin s'occupe de culture aussi
hein c'est pas d'accord merci merci
beaucoup vous et puis vive la culture à
50 ans qui est bien vivante he pour bien
vivante elle est très importante elle
est au cœur de nos préoccupations en
tout cas merci merci à
vous